this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you guys I thank you friends
for for coming it's amazing our semester
has gone by so quickly butts and my
dissertation focus on a horticultural
mineral oil called civitas and
horticulture motor oils have been along
for a really long time and we sue might
think why we might just renewed interest
in studying horticultural oils and it's
mainly because over the last decade
we've tried to reduce our chemical
inputs on to turf grass systems and
horticultural oils are generally a
non-toxic and they're low threat to the
environment so companies like
petro-canada to develop this product and
looking at safer alternatives of
commercial traditional pesticides to
minimize impact and satisfy Golf Tour
demand so kind of a quick seminar
outlines of the today's seminar will do
a brief introduction on spray oil
literature which goes back to the 1700s
we'll talk about the Civitas
developments over the last six seven
years and discuss some of the many
undocumented claims regarding this
product then we'll go into the
experiments I did where we characterized
response to the Civitas in the in the
field and then brought it down into the
growth chamber to do some physiological
assessments so spray oils have been used
in agronomy since the first published
article report was from 1787 and it was
well plant derived oils and then we had
the development of crude oil refinery
distilling there's an explosion of all
these different by process oil people
trying to figure out what they can do
with them and so in 1880 and 1890 cook
summarized some where people have been
doing looking at putting kerosene on
citrus and firing out that it had
beneficial effects to prevent insect
problems and then it was very common in
in vineyards to actually go out with a
25-percent emulsion of crude oil and put
it on apple orchards and vineyards to
help with disease pressure we've come a
long way since then
those old compounds are really a big
mixture of aromatics and unsaturated
hydrocarbons that can be kind of nasty
Hydra in toxic to plants and people now
we've come to these lower aromatic very
saturated compounds with narrow
distillation temperatures which is
pretty much a paraffinic spray oil that
we have today paraffin is this an older
term for an alkane if you're more used
to that terminology it's a fully
saturated carbon molecule some of the
consequences of spray oils the first
obvious advantages that we see control
of insect and insect pests mainly and
now we're actually seeing there
something impact on pathogen pass it's
got a low environmental impact and low
human toxicity some of the disadvantages
of however are they can they don't
guarantee control sometimes you'll have
breakthrough sometimes you won't have
great control with the products and
there's always a potential for
phytotoxicity even with the most refined
spray oils that we have today so here's
a picture of a conifer that was sprayed
with a dormant application of a spray
oil in the winter it was sprayed too
late it heat the temperature heated it
up and besides some some strong
phytotoxicity and his conifer so it's
common across all different crops that
these five boxes you can occur we also
see that these horror orioles are really
good spray adjuvant so mixing them with
traditional herbicides insecticides or
fungicides at lower rates we see better
control because these products help to
get the fungus the pesticides into the
plant I usually helping to get it
through the cuticle so here's an example
of a turf grass plot was surrounded by
dollar spot skirtini Romeo carpa then
mixed with a half of the low label the
rate of a really low impact a fungicide
are getting really good control of that
dollar spot disease but fine electricity
can be a problem if you look at the
literature there's kind of two types of
phytotoxicity there's a cute
phytotoxicity and that's direct damage
to the leaf so leaf lesions are common
if you have fruit you have sunburn but
really what it comes down to as the
membranes themselves
being damaged by these compounds this is
generally more true of the older
chemistry's that had a lot of aromatics
in them and a lot of unsaturated highly
reactive hydrocarbons for culture
Orioles today generally classify it as
chronically phytotoxic you see a
decrease in growth decrease in
photosynthesis transpiration and
respiration and this mainly because
because the oil persists on the leaves
and it blocks of stone mates and
inhibits gas exchange and you have all
kinds of feedbacks then that's going to
suppress these processes so now we're
generally about civitas it was developed
in the mid-2000s it's developed from
food grade ISIL paraffins which they
used to make everything from cosmetics
and lubrication to equipment that's used
for food processing I was labeled as a
fungus died in 2009 it also got armory
certified by the organic materials
research institute as a certified
organic product so that's great for its
use has limited funds a static activity
and the thing that makes civitas
different at least in the literature
compared to the other horticultural oils
is it's been found to induce this
Democrat systemic resistance so
application of this product Prime's
disease are primes genes in the plant
defense pathway so that when a pathogen
attacks the plan is really easily
quickly to respond to that pathogen
attack and suppress up the disease so
why isn't everybody using this product I
mean seems like it's great it's an honor
sir to fry product it helps out with all
kinds of myriads of disease issues and
plowed insect pests so there's a lot of
anecdotal claims that came out when the
product was first released the biggest
one was golf course superintendents
thought that their clipping yield on our
putting greens had increased and we know
that an increasing clipping yield can be
negative on a turf grass health
standpoint because it depletes storage
carbohydrates that could be used to help
recover from stress in the future and
then the other big thing for
superintendents is it reduced ball roll
distance so here's a picture
of a guy measuring ball roll it's a
pretty simple a little device it's just
a stick you lift it up when i get to 20
degrees the ball rolls off and then you
see how far it rolls on the green and
well me that although that may seem like
a silly thing that's really important to
golfers golfers associate fastball
distances with really nice high quality
facilities superintendents try to
maximize borrow and limit practices that
might somehow hinder ball roll distance
so we wanted this look in the girl
chambers to kind of see is the grass
actually growing faster and we have a
time-lapse to kind of show that it
appears that there is an increase in a
leaf elongation with the Civitas
treatment compared to the control it's
not super dramatic but it is seem to be
occurring and we've also mentioned this
in the field at putting green high turf
with some time lapse photography finally
the reason people look to this product
is in use that often or struggling to
gain acceptance as because it is
phytotoxic to turf and you can see in
the top left scripps corner there the
Civitas plot it's a little bit hard to
see with it's just projected but it's a
little bit more Brown a little bit less
healthy than the control and so the
company solves this by mixing in a green
pigment to have just paint the grass
green and so that really helps to
minimize that that problem so the onset
we had a lot of different questions and
it was really difficult to figure out
how exactly we're going to proceed i
came here lies different energy total
claims look at disco and i need to try
to figure out some kind of ways to link
all these different responses into my
dissertation that's okay here's a
roadmap now if I've gone through about
probably 15 different experiments in the
field in the growth chamber in the
greenhouse over the last six months have
been finally able to take those
experiments and try to make sense of all
these different results so we first
quantified the response of civitas in
the field by measuring ball roll
clipping yield and surface
characteristics like density and canopy
temperature on a fairly regular basis
then once you got a good sense of
going on in the field we were able to go
into a growth chamber look at
phytotoxicity and try to understand it's
a direct damage with for an acute final
toxicity or is it more of a chronic
damage then we expanded upon that
looking at gas exchange because most of
these modern oils have been found to
inhibit gas exchange info synthesis and
then finally if you're inhibiting gas
exchange what was that due to the carbon
dynamics of turfgrass plant so the in
the in my second chapter of my
dissertation the quantifying just the
equipping yield and the ball roll
distance now was the main objective it's
just kind of looking at equipping yield
and ball roll for ten days after we
applied the product we measured it every
single day I knew you'd at six times
over the course of two seasons then we
also want to look at some kind of
mitigation strategy if there is an
increase in ball roll so that this
product can gain acceptance in the in
the field our hypothesis was that
borrowed decrease was he in the field
was inversely related to the increase in
clipping yield with civitas and we were
hoping that the plant growth regulator
trinette sepak ethyl which is commonly
used to inhibit cell elongation might
actually mitigate that the client so all
these field experiments I'll just kind
of set them up here they've done a
bluegrass laying on a bed grass annual
bluegrass putting green and they are
maintained of standard practices so in
the clipping yield response study again
we had six ten day runs reflected
clippings every day and we had to
evaluate the different components of
civitas individually to try to get a
better sense of what's going on so we
have a control we have the Civitas soil
by itself the harmonizer oil with
pigment by itself then the mix of the
two which the company and is preferred
to industry is the 2-pack because you
mix it on site and then recently the
company Patrick Hannah developed civitas
one which is mixed at the factory it has
a different emulsifier so it does have a
little bit different prop research will
see the ball roll measurement then kind
of mirrored the clipping yields is just
done a separate separate putting green
and we looked at Bartle distanced over
the course of the day and then across a
10-6 10-day runs and we limited the
treatments here to just the control the
2-pack
the one pack steve has one and then with
them without this growth regular a trick
to exit pack FL which it introduces tank
grill so he's kind of a look at what
looks like in the field the Civitas and
then the 2-pack mixing the two together
and then the control and then har
manager by itself for Suffolk whipping
yield we found that everything that
every time we applied oil we had an
increase in clipping you whereas the
harm riser did increase clipping yield
and the control obviously as a control
there's two hypotheses here first it's
growing faster that's why there's more
clip clipping yield and that's kind of
supported by our time lapse measurements
the other hypotheses though is that the
oil itself may be contributing to the
weight of the leaves we'd only talking
about you know milligrams of tissue
difference here and so that's definitely
a possibility we think it's probably
some combination of both of them now
some of the oil has gotten down into the
canopy into the verdure and so not all
of it stuck on the word that's actually
being clipped but it's hard to actually
just say that the equipping yield
increase is only a fact of increased
growth rate so we looked at ball roll
distance and we saw that in fact the
ball roll distances did decline with the
Civitas to pack and even more with the
Civitas one pack these are practically
significant differences and Sicily civ
second differences so this is a level
that may not be acceptable to Gulf to
call for superintendents in the golfing
public it lasted for all ten days we see
an increase in ball rolls that each run
progressed because the the plots were
rolled and so as we were rolling in
every single day we increase surface
uniformly in the ball would roll farther
unfortunately there's no interaction
with the plant growth regulator and the
growth regulator only increased ball
roll by about seven centimeters which is
an even significant or practically
significant in the field golfers can't
perceive that small of an increase so
the growth regulator didn't help out
either although it did counter the
growth increase with the Civitas but so
if you look at this data and look at the
clipping yield data from the previous
slide you would then still assume that
as you had more clipping yield you're
going to have slower ball roll distances
so we did a correlation to see it as is
in fact the case we found out it doesn't
it's not true at all this has been
combined across all different days but
it was also done for each sing each day
each measurement within a day on each
run and there's only like handful of
occasions where there is a a correlation
of clipping yield and ball roll distance
and so this is important because
literature suggests that bottle distance
is correlated with clipping yield but
they never actually do correlations they
look at clipping yield and or and then
they look it'll use a product that looks
at it will put fertilizer down they'll
see the grass grows faster they'll see
the ball roll goes down and then I just
assume that oh the ball roll when town
because the grass grew faster but they
never actually did the correlations to
prove that and so I think there's some
some work that could be done there to
better understand this because there's
got to be some other factors high for a
lethal long Gatien as influencing ball
roll if it's the leaf of fiction the
firmness of the surface something we
need to figure out more and it so it's
so essential to management of the golf
courses quick conclusions civitas
increased clipping yield which is has
made potential implications for reducing
carbohydrate levels in the plant
borrowed the increased civitas did
reduce the bar role which could be a
problem for high-end putting surfaces in
their plant growth regulators just
didn't have enough enough of an effect
to really cancel out that that decline
of oral distance with civitas so then we
looked at the chronic phytotoxicity of a
civitas by first characterizing in the
field and then isolating the cause in
the growth chamber and we hypothesized
due to the nature of this oil that
civitas will reduce gas exchange which
is going to cause a chronic
phytotoxicity and that the harmonizer
mask this effect in the field so what we
did is we had another study at bluegrass
lay on the same putting greens to
describe previously and we had a
factorial 2 by 2 factorial we have
civitas the control and civitas and then
the oil by itself and then the oil and
the Civitas
the pigment by itself and the oil and
the pigment together and did turfgrass
quality rating which is kind of looks at
the uniformity of the surface the collar
of the density is very much subjective
but it's also very repeatable at the
same time we looked at chlorophyll index
with the CM 1000 to get a sense of the
amount of chlorophyll in the leaves and
campy temperature with a FLIR camera and
then at the end of the study we did
Taylor density counts so you're just
kind of a picture what this
phytotoxicity looks like at the end of
this growing season you'll notice the
control it looks a little thin it's at
the end of the growing season has been
warm the pole annual annual bluegrass is
starting to our be stressed out put the
home run that pigmentation really helps
surface look a lot better and I also
suspect that it actually helps the plant
to cope with some of the light stress
during the summertime the Civitas then
had the typical parodic appearance some
general thinning going on so starting to
have a decrease in quality and the
2-pack again had that same thinning but
then it's just still just painted green
with this harmonizer and so where the
grass did that I was very obvious by
these little flecks of blue so we look
more specifically at how a change over
the course of the year so we looked at
canopy temperature with a FLIR camera
and you can clearly see where the
controls out control plots are versus
the pigment and the oil and the mixture
of the two we did find that there's an
increase in temperature with the oil and
the pigment which you may expect and it
was definitely a function of solar
radiation so when it's sunny or out
there's a lot of differences if it was
cloudy or raining or cool generally
there is no differences between
treatments and all this may seem
significant the Kami temperature
increase is only an average half a
degree warmer with civitas and one
degree warmer civitas plus the the
pigment and even on the sunniest how to
stay in the summer that the increase was
only two degrees C so it really may not
be that and physiologically important to
have that small increase but it is as it
does suggest there may be something
going on like reduced transpiration
with the oil finally the final toxicity
with the quality this bottom line here
but this dash red is the Civitas and you
can see in the first year it was below
acceptable acceptable level of six for a
majority of the summer of the year
whereas the pigments civitas the solid
red line was at or above the level to
control the entire time the interesting
thing in 2013 was the civet the 2-pack
declined at the end of the year to a
level that was unacceptable and you saw
that in the last picture with the
thinning of the grass so thy policies is
this this humm rash was actually just
more masking this file toxicity because
in 2012 we didn't have the thinning we
had the chlorosis which was masked by
the harmonizer but then 2013 we had the
chlorosis and then the eventual
declining density which then obviously
can't be masked by a green pigment yeah
they're playing every two weeks yep at
the end of the study 32 density counts
and we found that we did definite the
climbing in stand density number of
tillers with the Civitas and the 2-pack
treatment compared to the control and
the hymen answer so this definitely is
some definite phytotoxicity happening
here and we wanted to figure out why is
this happening what caused this fire
toxicity with some implications of
reduced gas exchange with an increase in
temperature then how would that affect
photosynthesis and respiration and how
that affects carbohydrate pools so we
then went to the growth steam growth
chambers in wild hall for the rest of my
experiments will be discussing just to
kind of get it set up all the change all
the experiments happen in the same
environmental conditions unless they
were otherwise noted 30 degrees c during
a day 20 degrees c at night about 500
micro moles of for synthetic active
radiation per meter squared per second
for 16 hours and then we establish these
clones of annual bluegrass for three
months and once they were done stand
looking like this then expiry
happened and they were fertilized weekly
with a lower area nitrogen so
understanding phytotoxicity is a bunch
of small little experiments so we'll
just kind of go through these quickly we
look first at membrane disruption
because that's a sign of acute
phytotoxicity and to measure that we
just looked at electrolyte leakage and
we found that there was no treatment
differences relative to the control
which is good showing and get that in
fact these civitas isn't acutely
phytotoxic it doesn't damage the plan
anyway interestingly there was an
increase or decrease in electrolyte
leakage with the pigment although all
the values are really really minimal
which would suggest that the plants were
healthy and I believe we can explain
that because when you measure
electrolyte leakage you measure the
electrical electrical conductivity of
water it's got tissues floating in it
for 24 hours then you auto plate that
tissue you measure it again to see what
the potential amount of ultra
conductivity can be and I think what
happens is the pigment with this huge
chelate copper compound it probably
drops that that copper out so then it
increases the denominator of the
equation and dilutes the the luck slight
leakage number just because you're
losing the chelation of that copper ion
next let's look at scanning electron
microscopy of some turf grass leaves
treated with civitas 24 hours after
application and then again 48 hours
after application after a second
application of the product and we find
that there's some definite signs of
change in the morphology of the cuticle
where we have these nice platelets in
the control that degrades down and
becomes more flat we see oil persisting
on the stomata which may affect gas
exchange and actually may be beneficial
to pesticide absorption so we see that
the cuticle is it's being modified and
morphology wanted to verify that it
wasn't changing in quantity or
composition so we extracted the cuticle
off of leads treated with the five
different formulations of our parts of
SIP components of civitas and we found
in
at the top total iron chromatograph
these represent a lot of the waxy
components so you have some fatty acids
and then these are all primary alcohols
ranging from 22 to 28 carbons the
predominant one was a c-26 primary
alcohol hexic Olson all and that level
didn't then change with our response to
the Civitas there was however a really
pronounced civitas signature that was
found on all the pole ion chromatograms
from the GCMs and when we look at it
from a mole to mole ratio of total moles
of civitas versus the total mole of the
one hexa coulson all we find out this
between nine and 17 times the amount of
waxy oil substance on these cuticles and
there would be if they were just if
their natural and not treated finally we
did some gas exchange measurements with
a like or chamber it's gotten a rabid
opsys set up so we can drop our cohen
right in there and adjust the the light
intensity and make light response curves
and ACI curves really simply to look at
photosynthesis and respiration and what
we found was that civitas reduced met
radiation use efficiencies the the
Civitas one the blue line was uh was
more injurious than the Civitas to pack
our CEO tossed by itself and the pigment
had no effect this is only done 24 hours
after application and so we had to we
repeated this experiment to get a better
sense of how gas ian is being affected
but just looking at 50 toxicity we've
determined that acute file toxicity did
not occur and the wax at the cubicle wax
composition and content that was
unchanged but then there were some signs
of chronic phytotoxicity resulting from
that persistence of the oil which is
inhibiting gas exchange but more
research is required to figure out how
long does that actually last how bad is
it
so we designed the next chapter of a
thesis dissertation to look at how
civitas reduces gas exchange and so this
is this a lot higher a larger level of
measurements so these gas exchange
systems are really great because they're
super powerful and you can make carbon
assimilation or transpiration response
curves to factors such as photon flux
flux gradients which is Q or ambient co2
or internal co2 CA and CI because I'm
doing canopy level things I have to do
CA I can actually calculate CI because
of the can't measure individual leaf of
turfgrass you can also look at under
different vapor pressure gradients and
then from those models we can estimate
things like quantum yield rubisco
activity and respiration so hard lady
how do these devices actually work
here's just kind of a a graph of a light
response curve that I did I made my
stability be kind of quick so I can fit
it in the course of ten minutes but what
happens here on the x-axis you have the
time and then for synthesis and
transpiration on the y-axis and so the
process the fungus put in it's at 500
power and then once that stabilizes the
Machine automatically increases light
intensity two to a 2000 and then it
responds the once it comes into a stable
level which I defined and then here's it
wasn't entirely stable for this example
then the machine proceeds to reduce the
light levels or in the case of a CI curb
reduce the level of carbon dioxide in
the inmate chamber to measure folk
synthesis and then we can plot all those
those points where it makes a
measurement and we get these great late
response curves it tell us a lot of
interesting things the I y-intercept
talks about the maximum rate of
respiration like compensation point that
initial slope represents quantum yield
or the amount of carbon dioxide
molecules fix per photon then the
plateau represents the maximum posted
that capacity of that plant and that the
K as a result of either gay
diffusion inhibition or are you a BP
regeneration of limitations and in the
previous experiment were we showed the
late response courage this did a simple
anova and these experiments we used
regression analysis and so we salt been
able to then do regression and solve for
respiration the a max term and the
apparent quantum efficiencies the earth
the great thing too is we can look at
the transpiration rate and because
transpiration is a factor of leaf
conductance times the vapor pressure
deficit which we have we can fix with
the like or we can assume that
transpiration rate and leaf conductance
are a good proxy for each other on their
pre proportional and that can get to our
questions about the model inhibition so
we did to experiment we did one
experiment where you put a cone in the
like or they made in a huge curve at
different light intensities and then
right after that it went to an AC a
curve at different levels of carbon
dioxide with a constant relative
humidity and light level for the carbon
dioxide so we can have one vapor
pressure deficit value to them make
those comparisons on leaf conductance we
measured this when the control the
Civitas one and a civitas three hours
one two five and ten days after we
applied the products so what we do is we
get these big time courses where we have
three hours to ten days and then we
replicated our runs twice and so you'll
notice that for all these treatments
there was never a difference in
respiration so the Civitas dint affect
respiration but it did affect the a max
levels which then also means it affects
the quantum yield of the plant and in
two thousand in run one we had more
suppression of a max and run to and that
was a factor of a misapplication and a
little bit higher rate because the
nozzle was too close to the via the
campy leaves and so I got a little bit
higher rate and so it definitely showed
it there's a rate response and I've done
some experiments to show there as a
linear
responds with a max values but kind of
this to summarize what this shows is
definitely of an eat the decrease in
radiation use efficiency and respiration
wasn't affected and it takes ten days at
least for this effect to start to wear
off transpiration from that same study
again we have photon flux density on the
bottom there was a no interaction so as
we had brighter light intensity we saw
an increase in transpiration which makes
sense from a mass balance standpoint but
the Civitas had higher levels of or had
lower levels lower intercepts showing
that there's less transpiration and it
wasn't as dramatic about the client is
the light response measurements the
assimilation measurements and usually
recover within 24-48 hours by 48 hours
you can see that the transpiration race
it came back to the level of the control
which is interesting and then finally
bit look at the the ACA curves and this
kind of looks at the kinetics of rubisco
activity and carboxylation efficiency of
the plant so the initial slope
represents the initial carboxylation
efficiency of the plant and then the
y-intercepts represent the respiration
rate and they'll notice first of all
respiration rate was different it's a
little bit lower with the Civitas
treatment and that results from for an
increase in photorespiration because
these are all at the same light
intensity of 400 or 500 micro moles of
power and so this this data kind of
represent indicates that is reduced
carboxylation efficiency and increase
for rest for respiration and we know
that when you have a decrease in gas
exchange that activity of rubisco
declines because we're busy takes a lot
of energy to keep or bisco in an active
state especially if it's limited for its
substrate and these curves suggest that
the the plants are substrate carbon
dioxide limited and therefore they have
a decline in in roble activity and then
finally looked at gas exchange carbon
assimilation as a function of
transpiration rate which is the proc
see you again for for gas exchange and
leaf conductance and we find with the
Civitas one that there is a really
strong increase in cart in folsom nas's
back to kind of level of the control as
we had higher transpiration rate so this
could suggest directly that some model
conductance is actually was inhibiting
this for this carbon assimilation right
the Civitas itself a little bit less
which makes sense because that's
reflected back on the the light response
assimilation curves another thing to
note to is after this this initial part
where it's really linear or fairly
linear that occurred early after we
applied and then later on after we
applied the Civitas it came back to be
less of a function of transpiration rate
so that suggests that it's an inability
of the plan to utilize all the carbon is
taking in from the from transpiration
from gas exchange again suggesting that
rubisco is probably somehow inhibited
through some kind of inactivation later
on into the each run so the conclusions
civitas definitely reduced carbon
radiation use efficiencies and
transpiration gas exchange for a period
of 10 days and the carboxylation
efficiencies were definitely reduced as
a as a function of that decline in gas
exchange measurement so then it leads to
our final questions is so okay now we
know is less full sentences have
occurring less assimilation of carbon
what's happening to the partitioning of
carbon and then my question would be you
know where's this reduction in gas
exchange have effect on oxidative stress
in the plant so the final chapter of my
dissertation we looked at civitas
altering carbon dynamics we measure
plant biomass partitioning and the
measure concentration of storage
carbohydrates this experiment was
designed to simulate stressful
conditions so it's under really high
light intensities in that partly because
we find that as light intensity
increases is a bigger disparity between
the Civitas level and
the control for carbon assimilation so
that way we kind of exacerbating it's
definitely a worst term a worst-case
scenario additionally it led to some
episodic daily water stress so we kind
of could evaluate how civitas affects
plant stress how much does something
that's marketed a lot that is useful in
helping plant health so we re applied
civitas and wilt stop a commercial
transplant I transparent biweekly and
then measured carbon partitioning and
quality and gas exchange over the course
of eight weeks to get a sense of how
carbon perdition is changing so first we
did confirm that the Civitas and the
will stop reduced carbon assimilation
and transpiration goodbye about you know
ten to fifteen percent this is measured
fifth two weeks after we applied so
there is even lasting inhibition of
carbon simulation two weeks after
application we look at it there wasn't
an interaction with with weeks after
treatment but we did find that in the
first four weeks was kind of a general
increase in carbon assimilation and
transpiration and I think that is a
function of the plants adjusting to the
new higher light intensities however the
episodic drought stress had occurred it
started to really deteriorate plant
health and from at week six and at week
eight there's a dramatic decline in
carbon assimilation and transpiration or
a theater that that a high-stress
environment so how did it change biomass
clipping yield was the only thing that
was significantly different in biomass
and was civitas civitas had higher
clipping yield again again the time
lapses would suggest that it's actually
am that there is some growth component
to that but it could also be the weight
of the oil and counter that though will
stop does have weight itself so then you
also expect to see an increase and we'll
stop that didn't occur there's no change
in the above-ground biomass or the root
mass although there was a trend of
decreased root mass with civitas and the
water contents were the same across the
three it's also obvious too there's no
interaction between treatments and weeks
after treatment but on week eight we
start to see that as a drum at
change in the mass of clipping yield and
especially the route to shoot ratio you
know at week two there's about double
the amount of readers there is two there
are roots and at week eight there's
nearly you know seventy percent the
amount of roots and there are above
ground tissue so that draws dress is
definitely changing how carbons being
partitioned in the plan and we see a
decline in water content as a result of
that drought stress so how does civitas
effects effects storage carbohydrates
when we put civitas down a reduce the
starch in water soluble fructans in the
turfgrass so we think about water
soluble [ __ ] hands as turf graphs turf
grasses currency and if you ain't doing
any can practice that's reducing the
amount of sugars in the plant then
you're potentially reducing the plants
ability to recover from stress later on
during the year interestingly for the
weeks after treatment the starch levels
decline with drought status stress but
we see an increase in water soluble
carbohydrates as the stress continues on
over the course of eight weeks which
some of the literature suggests is would
be consistent with literature and
suggests that it's the plant then
preparing for for regrowth once that
stress ends and so finally we looked at
soluble sugar response to these efforts
episodic drought stress and so these are
the main sugars that were found in the
above-ground biomass of our turf grass a
fructose glucose and sucrose
myo-inositol sorbitol and trio lows
there was no interaction with treatments
for my on also tall so they were all
pooled together and we noticed some
interesting trends first looking at two
weeks of four weeks after application in
notice that the treatments are all
physically the same and then as that
drought stress episodic stress really
picked up then we had a real divergence
in the level of soluble carbohydrates in
the tissue and the plant you just have a
soluble carbohydrates for osmoregulation
and it also can use them for signaling a
plant stress so if we focus just on the
eight-week measurements we noticed that
for fructose and glucose we see an
increase in those those sugars
with the Civitas compared to the control
and the wheeled stop was in between
however for the sucrose there wasn't an
increase between the Civitas and the
control plan so the control really had a
dramatic increase in sucrose which the
turfgrass literature and Kentucky
bluegrass suggest sucrose should
increase during drought stress to help
it with osmoregulation then look at
sorbitol and triolo some stress sugars
we find especially with the tree loss
that there is not a response to drought
stress with trios composite content
whereas the control did increase under
that drought stress so it brings up some
questions they're really unclear
currently in to require a lot more
experimentation understand how civitas
is actually affecting plants shrubs
dress tolerance but from this there's
potential that maybe the Civitas is
actually hindering normal plants traps
drought a stress response and if you
look at the quality inn which i didn't
present you would notice that the
Civitas probably handled this the
drought stress worse than the wilt stop
or the control did so there is some
potential that this could be a negative
response that that the planet is not
proceeding the drought with the Civitas
application so kind of in conclusions we
see the increased clipping yield in
civitas at the expense of carbohydrate
accumulation which has implications for
distressed tolerancing going back to the
beginning of the study that could relate
to that decline in turfgrass stand
density by the end of 2013 we did see
the the obvious improvement instr did
not see in an obvious improvement when
turfgrass stress tolerance with civitas
which is kind of contrary to what their
marketing campaign would suggest and
we're still unclear why soluble sugars
responded that the way they did it will
require some future experimentation so
the kind of look full circle what's
what's happened we've shown that civitas
effects clipping yield and ball roll
which may limit its application the
putting green but saw its potential for
you know fairways and roughs and tee
boxes and
buttock fields in other places that want
to reduce their pesticide usage and
there was this phytotoxicity that
results from this product and it's
definitely a chronic toxicity from still
model innovation which reduced potion
assistant transpiration and Carbonite
the carbon dynamics indicate that we
have a decrease in soluble or in storage
carbohydrates with the Civitas so some
future experimentation would be looking
to Mai's the dose-response you know
everything I did here was a worst-case
scenario if I go at less of a rate we'll
have lots of effect on physiology but in
counter to that will have a less of
effect on that disease priming aspect
that's use the product is used for we
also measure oxidative stress of
inhibiting gas exchange is easy to
believe over some difference in
photorespiration and photo inhibition we
should look at the formulation of the
product right now it's a pretty wide if
they're all paraffins but they range
from 16 carbons of thirty three carbons
generally products are the less
phytotoxic like a JMS toilet oil they
have really really narrow ranges of
paraffin chain length and so potentially
maybe there are Frank components of
civitas they are phytotoxic and they're
not Li increasing the plant defense
specifically I saw a paper recently got
published like a couple weeks ago that
showed a 16 carbon alkane he's been
found to prime and do systemic
resistance and has a lot of potential to
be the active ingredient of civitas and
so we should look at that formulation
more closely and then finally I'm try
understand how civitas affects stress
tolerance because this product is being
applied during the stress of a summer
season and we should get a better sense
of how that has actually occurring so I
like to thank a lot of people especially
my committee Frank and then dr. Sutter
Bergstrom Zurich and Marty Petrovic I
think my research text Mary learn right
well Jim undergrad Jordan Gary and
Angela fever who tirelessly counted
did a lot of things like ball roll
measurements every day and cleaning
grass clippings and counting tillers
it's not fun work I could thank
petro-canada because they funded my PhD
and also Michael pfeffer who's a lead
scientist who developed the product is
very very helpful for all to work with
good thank Bill Miller helping with the
carbohydrate analysis fresh and rose
Harmon for actually helping me do the
analysis twice so I good thank God lying
Chang for in time wit low for let me use
her like or and the be a wild hall plant
care people especially Nick that neck
because who I was very very helpful well
selecting my fiance Katie because aside
from her helping me do a lot of lab
analysis on weekends she's always very
very supportive you on occasion she's a
sweet caring compassionate person and
then all my friends that have helped me
survive this three and a half years at
Cornell and helped me survive at burger
barn so with that I'll take any
questions and thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu